the wildly talented casts of knives awls
consists of former superheroes super
spies and a few legendary Hollywood
superstars like Jamie Lee Curtis Don
Johnson and Michael Shannon to name only
a few but where have you seen the rest
of these familiar faces before well
here's a handy who's who for Ryan
Johnson's whodunit knives out unless
you've been living under a rock for the
past decade chances are good that you're
familiar with Daniel Craig and his
prestigious body of work
the English actors breakout role was out
of the iconic double O agent James Bond
in 2006 s Casino Royale it was a role
that thanks to multiple sequels landed
him on Forbes world's highest-paid
actors list in 2015
however the handsome British far from a
one-trick pony over the years Craig has
excelled in a vast array of genres
ranging from drama sci 2002
oscar-winning Road to Perdition
to comedies like 20 17 s lucky Logan in
knives out Craig plays Benoit Blanc a
private detective brought son to
investigate the death of famous crime
novelist Harlan thrombi I suspect foul
play I have eliminated no Craig was
actually the first actor to sign on to
the project and he was apparently
flattered to have been offered the part
as he explained to cinema blend I hadn't
read something like that before and I
was just over the moon that Johnson
offered it to me with a lead like Craig
it's no mystery why so many critics are
crazy about knives out Agatha Christie
lovers Assemble
although the MC use Captain America
obviously won't be making an appearance
in Johnson's murder mystery Chris Evans
who's played the star-spangled Avenger
several times are since 2011 s Captain
America the First Avenger will be the
Boston Bread honkers flexes dramatic
abilities in films like before we go and
gifted but not as often as he's flex his
impressive physique in action flicks the
losers and Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
with an apparent affinity for playing
the good guy Evans has played not one
but two different superheroes first
starring as a human torch in the
Fantastic Four franchise his role that
ransom drysdale the knives out however
will be quite the opposite
Evans told Entertainment Weekly I'm
usually tasked with playing guys who are
a little more noble and this guy's a
little more vile it's fun although it
didn't exactly lights up the box-office
1992's the efficiency expert starring
acting legends
like Anthony Hopkins and Russell Crowe
marked the film debut of Toni Collette
in the decades to come
the Australian actress would enjoy a
highly successful career most evidence
by a massive award season love in 2009
she was cast as a lead role in Showtime
two United States of Tara
as Tara a mother coping with
dissociative identity disorder Collette
earned winds up both the Golden Globes
and the Emmys on the big screen the
actress has excelled in dramatic
comedies like Little Miss Sunshine and
about a boy however she's perhaps most
recognized for a work and a pair of
iconic horror flicks 1999's
unforgettably twist either Sixth Sense
and 2018 to serving the dark hereditary
in knives also decorated actress plays
Joni thrombi a lifestyle guru and
daughter-in-law of murder victim Harlan
thwomb a when speaking the deadline
Collette showered the murder mystery
script with praise saying it was all in
the writing in reading it just kept
opening up and changing and it was so
Swift and so smooth and so surprising
well Catherine Lankford's filmography
lacks in quantity it makes up for in
quality at the ripe age of 20 the
youngest rallyin actress landed the role
of elf fated high-school student Hannah
Baker in the Netflix mash series 13
reasons why Lankford stole the show as
Hannah even earning a Golden Globe
nomination for her performance her
newfound stardom landed her parts in two
movies in 2018 the misguided and loved
Simon
crickets way although she'd previously
worked with some fairly big names
Lankford was admittedly quite starstruck
when seeing her knives out co-stars in
action she told Yahoo TV I got so in all
of everyone I've watched all of these
people while sharing the screen with
a-listers like Daniel Craig and Chris
Evans must have been incredible the
young starlet who plays Meg thrombi in
the whodunit when Santa specifically
give praise to her fellow Aussie actress
calling Toni Collette a quote legend she
claimed that working with her was
amazing although her official acting
debut came in a Spanish film in 2006 Ana
diiemma says Hollywood career really
started in 2015 starring alongside Keanu
Reeves as Belle and the dark thriller
knock knock after that she played Myles
Tallis girlfriend is in war dogs and
then the holographic joy in the trippy
Blade Runner
20:49 although she's starring alongside
Daniel Craig in 2020s new Bond film no
time to die the gorgeous Cuban starlet
first shared the screen with him in
knives outs as Marta Cabrera the
recently deceased Harlan throm B's
live-in nurse the armas is one of the
prime murder suspects but while de Armas
admittedly had a wonderful experience on
sets shooting in Boston had one
particular downside she explained it was
my first time in Boston it was freezing
for a Cuban especially the actress may
have been cold but as she actually
knives out cold-blooded killer
life has been especially good for the
Keith Stanfield over the past 10 years
the California raised actors first big
break was getting cast as Marcus in
short term 12 alongside pre Lawson he
then was cast as Jimmy Lee Jackson in
2014 oscar-winning Martin Luther King
jr. biopic Selma since then his career
has really caught fire although is
appeared in popular films like get out
sorry to bother you and Netflix his
death notes
perhaps his most recognizable role is
that of the philosophical stoner Darius
in third or Glover's comedic drama
Atlanta not all great things conclude
great pain
sometimes love everything's a sacrifice
for knives alte Stanfield is playing
lieutenants Elliot a detective
investigating Harlan throm B's death
though he initially thinks that the
victim took his own life more clues
begin to surface and his character
starts to suspect something more
sinister is a first the award-winning
actor well much like the audience tried
to solve Ryan Johnson's whodunit check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bowel
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]